dude is much more dangerous with white
than with black so okay we do see a
kingspawn opening a sicilian defense
all right tonight comes out will we see
an open sicilian uh magnus he's been
relying on the sicilian a lot more in
the last few years
and okay it's gonna transpose to one of
my favorite openings the c3 sicilian the
aleppin
variation and uh white just wants to
build a pawn center magnus now
offering a trade in the center we do see
some very quick moves i'm surprised by
that last one by magnus
against me in blitz he always recaptured
there with the queen in the center
bringing his queen out early but uh yeah
very solid by black
seems he tries to avoid kind of possible
draw options and
now the game moved to
teresh defense in french opening kind of
a replacement and black is
gonna
suffer a little bit with isolated pawn
but of course magnus is hoping to get
the direct initiative
delivering the pieces to the center so
we we are wrong with magnus choice yeah
yeah so magnus did bring his knight out
but not to the usual square actually
black's knight normally parks itself in
front of the black king in order to
prevent any checks so magnus he's
opening himself up to some possible
checks right now games and uh top one
daniel dubov
okay so daniel dubois
yeah you're male players you have guinea
but uh a big big decision by magnus
carson ivanka yeah he's been played
before he's about to sacrifice the pawn
and it looks like it might be slightly
better for black okay better for black
wow so
i'm slightly surprised by this but she's
just developed a piece not choosing to
challenge magnus's idea just bringing
the bishop out supporting the knight in
the center on the outpost blocking this
isolated pawn and she's just saying okay
she wants to be solid instead but the
reason i'm surprised is because now
magnus at the very least can just bring
his queen out okay he brings it in a
different way but uh he brings the queen
out and now there's no issue at all with
black's position the opportunity to play
a6 bishop a7 bishop b8 that's very
very famous trick for the isolated pawn
like to get the battery we call it
battery on the long diagonal and giving
the checkmate also on h2 you have to
trade the dark squared bishops
especially so it was the opportunity to
give the check rookie 1 to develop the
bishop bishop p3 uh you called it you're
getting magnus is going for a very
similar plan to the one you mentioned if
we catch up with the game position he's
just dropped his bishop back one square
so he's hinting that he already wants to
drop it back again and create this
threat of a checkmate and white's king
actually lacks defenders around it so
love it when you at home
join in the action that they can see a
developing move and we love it when
you're part of the fun and the
excitement the show and following these
fantastic chess players another move yep
another move so white did bring a knight
out
develop that piece maybe the idea from
alexandra was to bring that knight over
to defend her king on the next move but
magnus has sensed the opportunity to
trade a set of pieces in the center at
least one set of minor pieces and now
white is going to get an isolated pawn
as well as black in the middle been
really unsuccessful in this game
can she just simply smile and go well
you know the opening didn't really work
out for me and then regroup
you know fix them
fix some some of those weaknesses yeah
in her defense the pawn structure is
pretty much symmetrical so if she can
exchange some pieces if she can survive
the next 10 15 moves then she'll
probably be doing okay but uh yeah just
this one bad piece makes her position
slightly inferior not only developed a
piece but also when the knight comes to
the square that alexandra's placed it on
the bishop can actually centralize
itself and start asking some questions
like okay you're defending the king for
now maybe black's position is just
slightly easier to handle and magnus you
can tell by the speed of his moves he's
just developing pieces he brought this
bishop out now he's brought his rook to
an open line he's just improving easily
while alexandra still has some questions
to answer like feels comfortable at the
moment for the reason uh there are no
like direct threats
he will try to force
alexandra to take critical solutions
okay
yeah almost there very similar yeah very
similar idea and the reason you mention
uh this move as well is because if
alexandra wants to trade pieces which
she probably does at some point then
this would at least allow magnus to
imbalance the position and um yeah
decent chances long term so instead
magnus has gone for a similar idea
planting is not in the middle of the
wood now white will never ever take this
knight because that would give black the
bishop pair and allow black to change
the pawn structure favorably um but
instead kostani brings her queen out but
uh magnus will try and line it up and
okay slightly surprising he's chosen to
move this rook to the e file
possibly just trying to avoid some
trades if he'd moved his other rook
which is maybe the
more natural move then this would have
allowed white to challenge some rooks
and pieces would disappear the advantage
would disappear as well so magnus go and
then moved it again for a second time
but uh then again there are specific
ideas behind it to justify that move and
now look at the central tension look at
the pattern of these pieces these nights
bit of symmetry there pawns
symmetrically yeah i have to say david i
really don't like what's just happened
now because i think alexandra was too
hasty to put her knight in the middle of
the board look good but magnus has
kicked it back and once the knight
retreats
then black can start doing this idea of
actually start asking some questions on
the dark squares he simply again gained
the tempo for for something else but uh
alexandre is uh
look at this magnus is going on the
attack he's not holding back anymore
he's trying to launch a pawn storm on
this king side um he's gonna maybe push
this pawn forward next push this pawn
forward dislodge the white knight get
rid of white's best defender and the
attack is brewing
relaxed
let's say
relaxed position using the chair
comfortable yeah and uh now she's full
in the game she understands
like a couple of moves are gone
look at this it continues upon pushing
forward again is this uncomfortable now
for alexandra
to actually get those polls just this is
not you basically this is terrifying
stuff kaya
no one wants this kind of situation
uh she can get in troubles and she has
to decide something with knight on f3 as
far as we see she played 92 she uh
continues the idea like trading the
pieces but it was like final warning
call for her all the way to the right
side once those lines are open
and uh okay i think
okay well we see some trades trades yeah
and then before very surprising no yeah
um you're surprised that black didn't
just take the bishop here and continue
um
i guess that would have involved a
change in pawn structure magnus just
wants to
control everything avoid any possible
counter play and castenia is struggling
for any ideas she's pushed her a pawn
forward
okay it wants to push forward and
destabilize the black bishop but maybe
the black bishop wants to move anyway
over the next couple of turns magnus
just securing his king securing the
seventh rank that white maybe wanted to
enter on later with some rocks or
queensland all those there are all those
threats on the board of uh just
pushing those pawns forward yeah i think
magnus will play for the attack here
some viewers at home might be wondering
why can't black get greedy just snatch
off white central pawn and probably the
answer is white i mean that is possible
black can just go upon up if he wants
but why bother the interesting thing in
chess yes i agree that's the end of the
game and talking of checkmate magnus is
lining up an attack against the white
king look at that black queen and the
black bishop they're on an open diagonal
that black queen
i mean how are you going to stop it
entering yeah well steny says she
doesn't even want to stop at entering
maybe there was no way to do that black
can just win on the spot black can give
a check the king moves black can give
another check okay i thought black could
just give another check the white king
moves and then black could just grab
white's rook there was a pin on the e
file and
magnus would just have won a rook for
free but okay he's trying to break
through if that white bishop now moves
then black's queen will just come down
one square and that's going to be
checkmate the white king is trapped um
magnus just putting his head in his
hands but he's got this game wrapped up
and
okay because then it does try and grab
the pawn as we showed black gives a
check and black did capture a pawn and
just there's an unstoppable threat in
the position pretty much rook takes
bishop next move black's rook taking the
white bishop with check will actually
unleash a discover check uh discovered
attack sorry against white's queen as
well the queens they're on the same
diagonal and white's queen at the very
least is gonna fall uh black will
capture it with his bishop or rook and
that's just game over and okay cassini
does run away with her king
um again plenty of winning moves here
but just okay i was going to say either
bishop takes bishop or a check first and
this is very effective magnus wins the
white bishop and
okay resigns a bishop down in a hopeless
position all right
that is a very nice win for magnus
crossing in
game one